lakers do not have another timeout
horton tucker throws it up what a bad
shot
but he gets it right back at school oh
my goodness and he scores
what a can you believe that sequence
i don't know what kind of a shot this is
heaven no
idea but it gets bounced around
and goes right back to him and he scores
unbelievable yeah
shake your head because you won't have
that happen again in your career not
that kind of a shot
and a result you know that's a good play
by marc gasol joking was honing in on it
yeah
and gasal got his hand on it and poked
it free and thc was right there here it
is again the little things that
you don't see in the uh box score
yeah great play and again give horton
tucker credit
the joker knows it he's like are you
kidding me now you gotta you said now
you got to make sure you put five guys
out there that can play
defense around the perimeter also i
don't know what kind of a shot this is
i have no idea
but it gets bounced around and goes
right back to him
and he scores got to do whatever they're
doing quickly and jokic
is going to fire it over to capaco
history blocked by
davis lakers are going to win it don't
give up the three
compazo shoots it but he doesn't elevate
anthony davis does gets the block and
secures
the victory what a good win for the
lakers here tonight
as they win their 37th game
of the year the victory what a good win
for the lakers here tonight
as they win their 37th game
of the